Hey guys, what's up!
So really awesome Tom Holland explaining little
bit about the MCU iron spider suit.
So he actually spent a lot more than was in
this clip so let's break it down the clip
itself is part of a Dell integration that
they hired him for but they also kick money
in for the movie like he talks about happy
Hogan Tony Stark using Dell computers it's
all product integration for the movie but
he actually talks about the scene that they
have that seems like it's on their field trip
to the Washington Monument when Ned leads
helps him hack into the suit.
So they learn about all its features before
he tested out in full.
I always love it when they recontextualize
stuff that we've already seen with new commentary
like this like normally you think this is
them just hang out.
Spider-Man getting a little stir crazy wanting
to be a hero but there's so much more going
on in this scene, so they teased a couple
of the new abilities that the suit has in
speaking of which there is a new round of
the Spider-Man giveaway it's a $20 comixology
giftcard all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and leave a comment on this video,
you probably saw the promo they revealed a
little while ago.
The just highlighted a couple of the suits
new abilities
we actually saw him use the holographic display
at the end of Civil War when he was looking
at the spiderlike.
So from the comics.
It just the spiderlike, but obviously the
MCU they change the little bit make it a little
bit cooler.
So it just the holographic readout of all
kinds of information that the suit is taking
it in so it has sensors all over it.
So the only like tease a little bit about
what it can do in this promo the neck and
revealed every single thing before the movie
comes out the web fluid is another big one.
The two different kinds that you actually
see in the trailer or when he's taking the
robbers down that sort of like the normal
web fluid.
But then later when he's trying to say that
big Barry you see the hard-core web fluid.
So this is really just the beginning.
I know a lot of people are thinking that Tony
might take the suit away from them at some
point in the movie and then give it back to
him, because at the beginning he says you
know the sutures to keep, but you're not an
avenger.
Then later in the trailer you see him fighting
the vulture.
So it's hard to tell whether or not that's
a prologue to the events that are happening
in present day after Civil War or is that
something that happens later in the film,
but if you're looking for surprises the probably
save you know special Stark tech surprises
the big action set pieces like this fairy
save.
Now, whether or not Iron Man comes to help
him out in this moment this is just a test
of his strength, so he is one of the strongest
avengers next people like Thor or the hold.
So he can actually do a lot of this without
all the extra Stark tech, but it's the tech
in the suit.
The takes him that extra mile things like
the web wings which is also a comic book classic
will help him with the vulture because now
he can glide through the air, even when he's
not in proximity to things that he can swing
off of that's his big weakness.
If you dropped him out of an airplane at 30,000
feet unless he could web himself up a parachute
he would be sh*t out of luck, which is why
he does much better in tight spaces like you
find in New York City amongst all those buildings
they don't really tell you in this footage
either, but there's also this funny implied
thing where Tony Stark sort of gives in the
suit and pushes them out the door like here
you go Kate good luck figured out on your
own.
So that's why he has to turn to his friend
Ned leads and a lot of people like hey wait
a minute Peter Parker is a scientist, even
though he's really young he still very smart.
He made that first suit all by himself.
He made his own mechanical web shooters.
So he's actually really good.
But I think what they're trying to convey
with some of that is that Spider-Man in high
school is building a team around him whereas
someone like Tony Stark is a little more independent.
He does have pepper pots but if you go back
and watch those old Iron Man movies.
He mostly takes her for granted for the first
couple times and then eventually he starts
to acknowledge her contributions which is
one of the many reasons why she's probably
not around anymore other actually real life
reasons for that to like Gwyneth Paltrow just
isn't necessary for Captain America Civil
War like like you don't need her you don't
need Jane Foster to sell movie tickets.
That's why a lot of those extra characters
don't show up again in these big Avengers
films Stark Tower is your baby 12% 12% target
and treatment for the 50th 12% were like all
the heavy lifting, literally I lifted everything
and start with the security snafu that was
on the all my personnel that are happening
on elevator it was teaming with sweaty working
I'm going to pay for that, just in some subtle
way later onto, but the really cool thing
is that Avengers infinity war start shooting
on Monday.
Now all the actors don't all shoot their scenes
at the exact same time Tom Holland will be
promoting.
Spider-Man homecoming for most of the spring.
So he's not going to be around as much as
the other actors, but the Russo's, who are
in charge of everything teased that he will
have some upgrades for the suit when he gets
to infinity war what does that mean though
they're probably not going to change the colors
that much is really just the stuff that you
don't see that doesn't stick out like you
don't see the spiderlike you don't see the
different fluid you don't see the web wings
unless he actually activates those.
So the be a lot of things that you don't see
unless he's actually using them in the way
that the Iron Man armor as well as the war
machine armor have a lot of extra abilities
that you don't see unless they actually activate
them war machine is probably the best example
of a suit with a lot of hidden features but
Iron Man always saves all the coolest toys
for himself but he's passing some of them
onto Spider-Man.
So the first movie will be a slow introduction
to that and then as their relationship developed
Spider-Man becomes an official avenger will
get extra little things to add to the suit
that will help him depending on the villains
that they pick usually the abilities that
the hero has or the special tech that he gets
has some critical function that helps them
defeat his villain like the ability to AI
pilot all of the armors and Iron Man three
or even the special lasers and Iron Man two
like the extra powerful laser or the different
energy sources.
Even the arc reactor itself.
I don't think that ever put an actual arc
reactor in the Spider-Man suit, but would
it not be bad ass.
If the spider symbol lit up like it does in
the comics like it has to be powered by some
energy source.
So Stark is probably figured a way out to
use his arc technology in a less visible way
than is Iron Man suit but congratulations
to the new Spider-Man giveaway winner Desi
Martinez please private message me on the
back and my channel so I can get your contact
details was a new round that started in this
video please leave all your requests for Spider-Man
bonus videos in the comments.
There is so much Spider-Man stuff that we
gotta talk about this year.
So next video will probably be flash season
three tomorrow morning.
While you guys wait for that to post you can
click here to learn all about the miles morale
is movie that Sony and Marvel are making and
you can click here for defendant behind, really
soon.
So much watching everybody high five I'll
see you guys